[Musique]
les 27 et 28 octobre s'est déroulés à la
norvèle le salon de l'emploi le
département est présent comme chaque
année pour présenter aux visiteurs les
solutions d'accompagnement et de retour
à l'emploi proposé par la collectivité
cette année le Conseil départemental
propose un tout nouveau dispositif le R+
Cie à l'instant heure plus qui a été à
destination de la complément de revenus
pour le bénéficiaire RSA le R + C2
permet également de
de dire à l'entreprise bah écoutez nous
vous accompagnons pour
recruter sur le marché de l'emploi des
bénéficiaires du RSE cette mesure c'est
indemnisation en faveur des employeurs
qui font cet effort sont les en remercie
pour recruter un bénéficiaire du RSA le
stand du département était également
animé par les conseillers du service des
ressources humaines
ce qu'il faut savoir aussi qu'au
département au niveau de la direction de
la DRH on publie toutes les semaines
toutes les quinze jours de nouvelles
offres d'emploi on a un champ de
compétences très large ça part du sport
de la culture
à la protection des forêts
la préservation de l'eau les personnes
âgées la solidarité donc on a un champ
de compétences très très large on a
autant des médecins des fébricultrices
des travailleurs sociaux des agents
administratifs des agents dans les
collèges et c'est pour ça qu'on
conseille aux gens d'aller sur le site
internet du département de regarder s'il
y a une offre qui correspond à leur
profil à ce que ils veulent faire de
postuler sur cet offre ou alors de faire
une candidature spontanée en tant que
pilote du plan départemental d'insertion
la collectivité participe à la lutte
contre le chômage en accompagnant les
publics les plus vulnérables vers
l'insertion
[Musique]